do you think that you could play in the  NBA and be the same Mouse gear that you  are in the NFL adjusting myself to that  game I definitely think I could have  been an elite player who is the best  basketball player in the NFL  man I'm taking myself out the equation  yo I knew you would but if you was you  would get my vote who else you got for  your boy BK Metcalf obj is good at  everything Mike might be number one yeah  I probably got a basketball goal in the  Browns facility you have a dunk on  anybody cause I ain't dunking anybody on  the the brown facility we start pulling  out the hoop like this year this year  and last year and so I didn't really get  to catch anybody under the round